>>> DEMOCRATS ON CAPITOL HILL
NOW APPEAR TO HAVE THE 50 VOTES
IN THE SENATE TO MOVE FORWARD ON
THE INFLATION REDUCTION ACT.
DETAILS OF THAT BILL WERE AGREED
UPON BY SENATORS CHUCK SCHUMER
AND JOE MANCHIN LAST WEEK, BUT
THAT DEAL NEEDED A FEW LAST
MINUTE TWEAKS BEFORE SENATOR
KYRSTEN SINEMA OF ARIZONA WOULD
AGREE TO SIGN OFF.
WELL, SHE PUT OUT A STATEMENT
LAST NIGHT THAT SAID WE HAVE
AGREED TO REMOVE THE CARRIED
INTEREST TAX PROVISION, PROTECT
ADVANCED MANUFACTURING AND BOOST
OUR CLEAN ENERGY ECONOMY IN THE
SENATE'S BUDGET RECONCILIATION
LEGISLATION.
SUBJECT TO THE PARLIAMENTARIANS
REVIEW, I'LL MOVE FORWARD.
JOINING US NOW, INDEPENDENT
SENATOR ANGUS KING OF MAINE.
SO THERE SHE HAS IT, SENATOR
KING, THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
THIS MORNING.
SHE SAID PARLIAMENTARIAN, THIS
HAS TO BE SCORED, IF YOU'RE
GOING 50 VOTES WITH BUDGET
RECONCILIATION, IT HAS TO REDUCE
THE DEFICIT.
THAT PRICE TAG YOU'RE GOING TO
GET IS SO IMPORTANT.
ARE YOU CONFIDENT IT IS GOING TO
COME IN WHERE YOU NEED IT TO BE?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THIS IS ACTUALLY GOING TO REDUCE
THE DEFICIT.
ONE OF THE PROVISIONS IN THE
BILL IS TO REDUCE THE FEDERAL
DEBT BY $300 BILLION.
SO THAT WAS ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT JOE MANCHIN AND I AND
OTHERS INSISTED BE PART OF THE
BILL.
I DON'T THINK THERE IS GOING TO
BE ANY PROBLEM ON THE NUMBERS
SIDE.
THERE IS SOME SORT OF IN THE
WEEDS ISSUES ABOUT WHAT YOU CAN
DO IN A RECONCILIATION BILL IN
TERMS OF POLICY AND THAT'S WHAT
THE PARLIAMENTARIAN IS WORKING
THROUGH THIS WEEK.
BUT THAT WAS A BIG DEAL LAST
NIGHT, THAT WE NOW APPEAR TO
HAVE A FINAL DEAL THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE 50 VOTES FOR.
>> ARE YOU FEELING CONFIDENT
ABOUT THE SENATE
PARLIAMENTARIAN?
>> YEAH, I THINK SO.
I MEAN, AGAIN, IT IS A COMPLEX
PROCESS, AND I CAN'T SAY THAT
EVERY SINGLE PROVISION IN THE
BILL IS GOING TO PASS THAT
MUSTER.
INTERESTINGLY, THE PROCESS IS
CALLED THE BIRD BATH.
AND IT GOES BACK TO SENATOR
ROBERT BIRD WHO SORT OF INVENTED
THIS PROCESS AND YOU GOT TO GO
THROUGH THIS PROCESS WITH THE
PARLIAMENTARIAN TO DETERMINE
THAT YOU'RE REALLY DOING
ESSENTIALLY FINANCIAL CHANGES
RATHER THAN STRAIGHT UP POLICY
CHANGES.
I THINK IT LOOKS GOOD.
THIS IS THE SAME PROCESS, FOR
EXAMPLE, THAT THE REPUBLICANS
USED FIVE YEARS AGO FOR THE
MASSIVE TAX CUTS FOR
CORPORATIONS.
SO I THINK IT IS GOING TO CLEAR
THOSE HURDLES.
>> DO YOU THINK THIS WILL HELP
DEMOCRATS IN THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS UPCOMING?
>> WELL, I THINK THE FIRST THING
I WANT TO SAY ABOUT THE BILL,
HERE IS THE BREAKING NEWS, GUYS,
THIS IS A BIPARTISAN BILL.
IT IS BIPARTISAN EVERYWHERE BUT
IN THE U.S. CAPITOL.
THE MORNING CONSULT DID A POLL
THIS WEEK AND JUST GOING DOWN
THE NUMBERS, I MEAN, BASICALLY
THEY POLLED ALL THE INDIVIDUAL
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL, AND IT
IS SORT OF UNBELIEVABLE.
LIMITING ANNUAL POCKET DRUG
COSTS FOR SENIORS TO $2,000, 72%
FAVOR, 11% AGAINST.
MINIMUM TAX ON CORPORATIONS, 63
TO 21.
I MEAN, THE NUMBERS ARE ALL JUST
SORT OF OVERWHELMING IN TERMS OF
THE GENERAL PUBLIC, AND I'LL BE
HONEST WITH YOU, I REALLY DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY THE REPUBLICANS
AREN'T JUMPING ON THIS BILL,
BECAUSE IT REALLY IS -- IT IS
PAID FOR, IT REDUCES THE
DEFICIT, IT WILL HELP MAKE A
REAL DENT IN INFLATION, IT IS
GOOD FOR SENIORS.
THESE ARE THINGS WE SHOULD HAVE
DONE YEARS AGO.
IN FACT, THE FIRST BILL I
INTRODUCED WHEN I CAME TO THE
SENATE WAS TO HAVE MEDICARE
NEGOTIATE FOR DRUG PRICES.
THAT WAS TEN YEARS AGO.
SO I'M REALLY GLAD THAT THAT'S
IN THE BILL.
I THINK IT IS A BIG DEAL.
>> SO, SENATOR KING, BUT, THAT
REPUBLICAN OPPOSITION, WHETHER
IT IS BY REFLEX OR SIMPLY
TRADITION IS VERY PRONOUNCED AND
YOUR COLLEAGUE SENATOR LINDSEY
GRAM SENT OUT A TWEET STORM LAST
NIGHT, ESSENTIALLY THREATENING
DEMOCRATS SAYING A WORD OF
ADVICE TO THOSE WHO SUPPORT THIS
RECONCILIATION DEAL, DO YOU
EXPECT TO SEE A POLITICAL PAYOFF
WITH 60 VOTES, YOU MAY WANT TO
RETHINK, IF THERE IS SOMETHING
THAT CAN'T BE DONE IN
RECONCILIATION, IF I WERE YOU, I
WOULD GET IT UP FRONT, STAY
TUNED.
THAT WOULD BE A THREAT.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF IT AND WHAT
DO YOU THINK IT SAYS --
>> I DON'T REMEMBER --
>> GO ON.
>> I WAS GOING TO SAY I DON'T
REMEMBER HIM SAYING ANYTHING
LIKE THAT WHEN THEY WERE
MASSIVELY REWRITING THE TAX CODE
AND GIVING A HUGE BREAK TO THE
WEALTHIEST AMERICANS AND
CORPORATIONS.
SO IN ANY CASE, NO, I THINK THIS
IS A -- THIS IS A WINNER.
AND I'M -- THAT'S NOT MY
CONCERN, JOHN.
I'M NOT -- I'M NOT PLAYING ONE
SIDE OR THE OTHER HERE IN TERMS
OF POLITICS.
I JUST THINK THERE IS SOMETHING
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WANT.
IT IS GOING TO HAVE AN IMMEDIATE
IMPACT, IT IS GOING TO HAVE A
LONG-TERM IMPACT ON EVERYTHING
FROM ENERGY PRICES TO DRUG
PRICES TO NEGOTIATING DRUGS FOR
SENIORS TO HAVING BILLION DOLLAR
PROFIT CORPORATIONS PAY THEIR
FAIR SHARE.
NOW, I SAY FAIR SHARE, HELL I'LL
SETTLE FOR ANY SHARE.
RIGHT NOW THEY'RE PAYING ZERO.
THERE HAVE 150 COMPANIES PAYING
ZERO.
THIS BILL SAYS, HEY, YOU GOT TO
PAY AT LEAST 15%.
HOW DO I EXPLAIN TO A COP IN
PORTLAND, MAINE, PAYING $5,000
OR $10,000 IN TAXES THAT HE'S
PAYING MORE THAN A COMPANY THAT
IS REPORTING A BILLION DOLLARS
WORTH OF PROFIT?
SO I THINK THIS NOT ONLY IS GOOD
POLICY, I THINK IT IS GOING TO
BE VERY POPULAR IN THE COUNTRY.
>> SIR, THANK YOU, FOR BEING
WITH US.
SENATOR ANGUS KING.